our immune system is a complex one which
involves many different parts of the
body working in sync together our immune
system shields our body against diseases
of viruses and infections when working
properly the immune system identifies
and attacks viruses bacteria and
parasites while separating them from the
body's own defense tissue but we tend to
forget is that our gut is the center of
the immune system and that's why really
to keep this part of our body healthy
I'm gonna share with you five super
drinks which are packed with essential
nutrients for everyday health and we
should all be drinking them every day in
the morning first hot lemon and ginger
team drinking a huge glass of warm lemon
water first thing in the morning it's
something I've been practicing for many
years not only does it help with
hydration it is rich in vitamin C and
also aids your digestion and soothe
inflammation ginger is not to increase
blood circulation reduces pain and can
fight against infections flu and cough
ginger helps flush out toxins in the
colon liver and other organs which
supports the entire digestive process to
make with tea slice one whole lemon in
half squeeze the juice from one half and
slice the rest either into a jar or two
cups then thinly slice about one inch of
a fresh ginger root and add it in fill
the pot with about one cup of boiling
water and leave it to steep for three
minutes if you want to you may choose to
sweeten it with a little bit of honey
this is a very easy immune boosting tea
recipe which you can make in large
batches for you and your family to keep
them healthy
the second drink is turmeric and ACV
detox water I'm sure we've all heard
about the amazing health benefits of
consuming turmeric which is a root
vegetable and spice used in many South
Asia and Southeast Asian cuisine the
bright yellow pikmin
active ingredient in turmeric curcumin
and it has powerful antioxidant
anti-inflammatory and antiseptic
properties apple cider vinegar contains
healthy bacteria and can help to keep
our digestive system working properly it
can also help to lower blood sugar
levels to make this detox drink add one
tablespoon of apple cider vinegar with
quarter teaspoon of turmeric powder and
one teaspoon of honey or maple syrup
into one cup of warm water stir it and
drink it immediately the next is my
favorite green smoothie a vegetable base
green juice is a powerhouse of nutrients
for a strong immune system I like to
make mine with spinach celery and
tomatoes these vegetables are bursting
with vitamin A K C calcium iron
potassium and magnesium drinking a glass
of green smoothie in the morning is a
great way to jam pack your body with
antioxidants and vitamins to kickstart
your immune system they are also very
easy to make filling and can be a great
breakfast plus they are low in sugar so
in a blender add about one cup of baby
spinach one stalk of celery one sliced
tomato and one cup of water
blend it up the great thing is that you
can mix it up and choose other leafy
greens or if you like it to be a little
bit sweeter than adding a fruit of your
choice another great immune boosting
smoothie to make is a root smoothie
consisting of all root of vegetables
including bigs carrots ginger and
turmeric inflammation is often an immune
response to infections which can cause
flu or cold symptoms like runny nose
cough and body aches this movie is one
of the best recipes for coast it can
boost your immune system and decrease
inflammatory symptoms to make it add 1
small cooked beat 1 chopped carrot and
of root ginger quarter teaspoon of
ground turmeric and one cup of water
blend it up this movie is also extremely
filling but low in sugar and packed with
nutrients and the final drink is simply
water you have something so simple that
we often take it for granted
water is essential regardless whether or
not you want to keep your immune system
healthy as it keeps us hydrated which
keeps all the organs in our body
functioning drinking enough water on a
daily basis can help to flush out any
toxins from the body thus enabling the
immune system to function as normal
water also regulates our body's
temperature helps with nutrient
absorption and boost our energy up to
60% of our body is water so without it
you won't be living or functioning at
your best hence this is why I always
emphasize on drinking at least 2 to 2.5
liters of water more than 70% of our
immune system is in your gut and forms
at the foundation of your health if you
want to remain healthy your immune
system should be working properly it
needs a solid dosage of vitamins and
minerals daily to keep its vitality up
and going so be sure to incorporate
these super drinks in your morning
routine if you enjoyed this video don't
forget to give it a thumbs up share it
and subscribe to my youtube channel and
do also check out my channel for a lot
more daily workout videos to keep you
active so stay home stay safe and stay
active all the best